the Pokemon company has unveiled a new
game for mobile devices called Pokemon
ko master I'm Lucy and welcome to this
evolving GameSpot news updates the
free-to-play experience mixes elements
of traditional Pokemon titles such as
capturing and battling with the strategy
of traditional board games such as chess
or go
although additional details haven't been
provided there also seems to be an AI
element to the game designed to help
players Pokemon ko master is developed
by Japanese company Haros which
specializes in creating artificial
intelligence its website states that it
has previously developed an AI and used
it to defeat professional shogi players
Pokemon commerce except for release
later this year in Japan but a Western
release hasn't been confirmed yet the
Pokemon company is of course owned fine
in Tendo which is expected to begin its
push into the mobile game space this
year with miitomo
a game developed in partnership with DNA
so would you play pokemon co master if
it came to the west let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for the
latest Pokemon adventures make sure you
keep it GameSpot
you